[Musik]
die lösung des falls maßen zeigt einmal
mehr dass die koalition an einem
seidenen faden hängt das war ein
kompromiss der den augen von vielen
nicht nur sozialdemokraten wie ein
fauler kompromiss aussehen muss klar war
dass die koalition nicht scheitern soll
und klar war auch dass maßen nicht mehr
verfassungsschutzpräsident bleiben soll
jetzt wird er natürlich befördert wird
einer neuen stelle versehen im ohnehin
an staatssekretärsposten reichen
bundesinnenministerium und er bleibt
weiter offenbar für die sicherheit
zuständig das heißt der dem man
angeblich nicht vertrauen kann wird
weiterhin noch verantwortungsvollere
position für die innere sicherheit und
womöglich cyber sicherheit deutschlands
verantwortlich sein und man sieht jetzt
schon dass das gerade die spd aber die
ja zugestimmt hat nicht beruhigen wird
und ob das der cds uhr aus der patsche
hilft ist auch mehr als fraglich aber es
ist erst mal ein kompromiss der wohl an
diesem faden halten wird zu maßen muss
man sagen dass er sicherlich durch seine
letzten äußerungen zu chemnitz starke
zweifel an seiner eignung geweckt hat
dass er aber auch dem verfassungsschutz
vorher gut gedient hat und dass er auch
angesehen ist in den sicherheitsbehörden
und dass er ein thema aufgegriffen hat
und dafür auch merkel immer hinter
vorgehaltener hand stark kritisiert hat
was weiterhin die menschen und die
koalition bewegt nämlich die migrations
krise die flüchtlingskrise die
einladungspolitik der bundeskanzlerin
und letztlich zeigt sich wieder unter
einem brennglas dass das nicht die
mutter aller probleme ist aber dass hier
noch weiterhin ein sprengsatz liegt der
auch jederzeit hochgehen kann
[Musik]